hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend I'm feeling good I really am
must be nice it is nice it's nice to
feel good while you're not feeling good
man I am I am feeling good really no I
feel but I still feel better than you I
know I do how do you know you can't
quantify that you can't see in my chest
I can I just feel like fight fight
you want us to fight no we're not gonna
fight about this I just feel uh very
good I feel like I'm reaching some kind
of peak in my life I think you are
feeling better than me because you've
got your collar open more than I have
and that's a sign of a happy person I'm
gonna even go down a button yeah yeah
look at that right there we've got about
the same amount of chest hair do you
guys have chest hair well I actually I
took care of my chest hair for a reason
what what yeah just the other day he
took care of it it you like assassinate
I shaved my chest hair why because I'm
gonna start doing porno oh
because I found out that you know
there's a strike going on right now and
you're not supposed to be doing any
writing and it's some of that porno is
not Guild covered that's the only thing
you did to prepare for the porn you're
about to shoot yeah and then it turns
out you need to like be able to function
and stuff
which I didn't know
so I shaved my chest and I walked in
there and I went I'm ready to go and
they said well can you can you kind of
work yourself up into a state of
excitement I went well I could if it was
1988.
you did shave your chest no I did why
I'm gonna tell you why I shaved my chest
for biking that's right biking what yeah
biking did you shave any your legs too I
shaved my entire body but you have arm
hair yeah I didn't touch that part but
you just said you shaved your entire
body to me entire body means chest uh
and then uh the whole no stomach area
okay what's below that what do you mean
I call it my
nether regions no I I didn't do that the
IC Delta yeah
full thatched roof
look we got to talk about some business
here this is the episode where we have
Quest love on yes we do have to talk
about this Quest Love Is it is it fair
to say a devotee of this podcast I
didn't know that and that's that's quite
humbling I think it is uh he's a he's
one of those connoisseurs of well
obviously uh seems like one of a hyper
cool person absolutely and uh he's
always curating music playlists for
people and telling people what to listen
to and then it turns out he's I'll use
the word geeky fan for our podcast which
uh was nice to hear I'm really nice to
hear and he's a great guy love talking
to him he Geeks out so much so that he
was aware of how long Jeff goldblum's
second appearance on this show his hi my
name is friend intro yes was because
most people say hi my name is you know
blank and uh I'll just throw in hi my
name is Tommy tuberville he was a great
interview
um and and uh I feel is that a person
yes yes he's the senator who's uh
holding up the entire military
appointments of our government just so
that he can make some point about oh
social justice okay something
um
yeah you thought Tommy tupperville was a
children's cartoon character literally
it literally didn't sound like
Cuba
Copperville
no he doesn't he's trying to make sure
that no one can I mean you would care
about this that women in the military uh
time well spent that's good that's good
well I'm sorry I'd have to explain
things to Sona I yeah he doesn't want
any social issues I'm not getting at you
okay yeah oh you're mad at me you
brought him up you brought him up
talking about Quest love do you want me
to back up and not talk about timing too
late yeah is it also tuberville well I
thought it was two and then I listened
to a podcast and they called him
tuberville what podcast did you listen
to It's called mispronunciation it might
be
no apparently I was convinced it was
tuberville and then I've heard several
things where they call him tuberville
now I'm part of this problem yeah
exactly so you guys you're really
helping by the way uh anyway very
controversial uh Senator at the moment
uh and irritating a lot of people anyway
that's not the point the point is most
people have a quick intro hi my name is
Harrison Ford and I feel shitty about
being Conor O'Brien's friend and then we
move on uh Questlove came on and was
aware that the record is held by Jeff
goldblum's second appearance Jeff
goldblum's second appearance where Jeff
went on and on and on
and it was it was that for a long time
and then Questlove came in on a mission
in to defeat Jeff goldblum's record
and the question is
did he no wow what wow he went on
forever I agree but I have it on good
authority from our man in the
engineering section Eduardo that he did
not beat him but that's reason to have
Questlove back yes and uh so that he can
beat it well because Goldblum got two In
fairness Goldblum got to try one out and
then he came in and he mastered the
whole thing yeah but I'm still shocked
because
as you know Questlove really stretched
it out yeah to the point that I left
yeah and I did some welding on a 1966
Volkswagen Beetle he also recorded
another podcast episode with a totally
different guest yeah and I made a
margarita pizza from scratch wow and
built the oven that I cooked it in and
then came back in and Quest slip was
still grow it was still going I got a
great idea what two podiums
two people two intros yes yes love yes
and third one
tuberville yeah I'm sorry
and it's just all him explaining how his
name's pronounced yeah and why he thinks
women shouldn't be allowed to to leave
get military leave uh to take care of
their female health issues yes sorry and
uh sorry tuberville but no don't
apologize
wow we were just gone for three weeks
and you have a
[Music]
his shaved little baby arm
oh nice please no it's not that let's
not get that rumor out there
waiting fingers no one has big dick
energy like Conan O'Brien you shave to
get be more aerodynamic on a bike I'm
making this all up oh okay yeah I wanted
to be able to ride without a shirt and
without pants and have no aerodynamic
drag
that sounds dangerous wait what so you
have no pants on So You meaning your
little guy is flapping in the breeze
first of all not a little guy quite
average to average just to be plus I get
a solid B plus a minus but isn't that
gonna cause some drag uh I got a lot of
compliments uh in the past from my
girlfriends with glaucoma anyway
no I I cut a hole in the seat oh so it
slides in there yeah sometimes when I'm
stopped at a light I just sort of wiggle
it around a little bit and it feels
fantastic if you get aroused on the way
that's the whole point yeah
let's start the episode I forgot my
kickstand no problem
oh my God my name is Dick joke Johnson
that's the kind of stuff you can expect
from the witty in Urbane Conan O'Brien
um let's get into this and let's hear
hey you gotta check this out because I I
do love this gentleman and you also have
to hear his intro they already have
oh right I forgot how the podcast you
never knew how the podcast worked I'll
listen to it one day I'm just not a fan
of the host
I get it